APES AINSLEY ONE CALIFORNIA
HOUSE SEAT SPHBLING FROM BLUE TO
RED, REPUBLICAN MICHELLE STEEL
DEFEATING HER DEMOCRATIC
CHALLENGER THE INCUMBENT IN A
VERY CLOSE RACE THAT COOK
POLITICAL REPORT LABELED LEAN
DEMOCRAT.
SO STEEL’S WIN ADDING TO THE
NUMBER OF WINS ELECTED TO
CONGRESS THIS YEAR.
MICHELLE STEEL JOINS US NOW.
GOOD MORNING CONGRESSWOMAN
ELECT.
HOW ARE YOU?
>> I’M DOING GREAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR INVITING
ME THIS MORNING.
AINSLEY: I’M SURE YOU ARE.
YOU ARE WELCOME.
CONGRATULATIONS ON FLIPPING THIS
SEAT.
HOW DID YOU DO IT.
>> I JUST STICK TO THE ISSUES
BECAUSE I ALREADY HAVE A PROVEN
RECORD.
>> LOWER TAXES AND LESS
REGULATION SINCE COVID-19 WE
CLOSED DOWN ALMOST 8 MONTHS
BUSINESSES BEING CLOSED DOWN.
I STICK TO THE ISSUES.
ANOTHER THING IS THERE ARE A LOT
OF PEOPLE WHO WANTS TO DEFUND
THE POLICE OR DISMANTLING.
INSTEAD I ACTUALLY DECLARED
ORANGE COUNTY LAW ENFORCEMENT
APPRECIATION DAY AND DO YOU KNOW
WHAT?
WE HAVE TO SUPPORT POLICE AND
ALL THESE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS BECAUSE 99% OF THESE
PEOPLE ARE GOOD PEOPLE WE
TRAINING.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE CANNOT
DISMANTLE OR WE CANNOT DEFUND.
I JUST STICK TO THE ISSUES AND I
THINK THAT’S THE REASON THAT I
WON.
AINSLEY: I KNOW YOU AND MARYLAND
STRICKLAND THE FIRST TWO KOREAN
AMERICAN WOMEN THAT HAVE BEEN
ELECTED TO CONGRESS.
SHE IS A DEMOCRAT AND SHE WON IN
SEATTLE.
TELL ME YOUR STORY.
WHAT MADE YOU WANT TO SERVE?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
ACTUALLY, FIRST GENERATION.
AND I WAS BORN IN KOREA, RAISED
IN JAPAN.
SO I SPEAK KOREAN AS MY FIRST
AND JAPANESE AS ENGLISH LANGUAGE
AND ENGLISH MY THIRD.
NEVER THOUGHT MY MOM ACTUALLY
WAS [INAUDIBLE] STATE BOARD --
THAT’S THE REASON THAT I DECIDED
TO RUN FOR STATE BOARD OF AND
THAT’S THE WAY I STARTED.
THIS IS MY FIFTH ELECTION.
I WON ALL FIVE.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT?
I STAND FOR AMERICAN DREAM.
AINSLEY: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF SO
MANY WOMEN MINORITY GROWING THIS
YEAR.
>> ME WITH MY ACCENT I STILL
WON.
AND PEOPLE ACTUALLY, WHEN WE
STICK TO THE ISSUES AND WE JUST
TRY TO WORK WITH RESIDENTS AND
WORK FOR RESIDENTS I THINK WE
ARE GOING TO KEEP WINNING.
AINSLEY: YOUR ACCENT IS PART OF
YOUR STORY.
YOU ARE A BEAUTIFUL PERSON.
YOU SPEAK THREE LANGUAGES AND
DON’T LET ANYONE TELL YOU